okay next part of the kuhn-tucker
we actually started taping back into
something a little bit more advanced
where instead of just tucking near the
body you extend your arm start to turn
this into wow
so this basic reveal sort of review
practice it's a tough turns
form
that
the real key points that I covered with
the sweet dreams of tough terms he spins
we should get
okay so with back to school turns
instead of just always going global
voice to get low or sleeping hi we can
do that sweet neutrals or click
windshield wiper sweeping across
across we can even serve invert the
relationship so if the koi are falling
down
they want a swing bound I can actually
raise those up sweep that in front of my
face like windshield wiper on the choir
singing in Reverse stead of going up and
over we got down
back as well
practicing nice
clean control
read emotion go and by the way for next
next week this is also this sweetman
front of our face there is essentially
getting us ready for just locking out
into shoulder wheels and
this suite right there
from our belly one is
lockout
plug this into life
from there we switch gears into anyone
asked people for requests who's keen on
hybrids which we're going to work up to
hybrids
basically involves having your head and
rubbing your tummy doing something with
one hand different thing the other and a
great way to start that out
forms a variety of Independence
you're spinning
so
basically
[Music]
you survivors here
over and extend um
practices against a wall because Pendle
is a really great test of whether or not
you've got really good plain folk
spinning
putting lots of tension into that that
helps button that you're playing easy
keeping a nice
controller boiling so depends on the
target keeps hitting is your over there
and there
so we play with that play with pendulum
practice your wool and
I
wanted people to explore whether they
really
turn their torso while doing that
and using this walls
see where you get to passing through
your plane
the real pinnacle of that you over here
you get a good angle on this
pinnacle that you're going for is being
able to
get my torso turned
but keep my arms close on the same sort
of plane or either right next to each
other
so that I'm understanding you're moving
my arm I'm actually using the turning of
my hips and movement of my whole body to
drive the point
from his own play we
we got into spinning
spinning forward together time same
direction and taxing just
stop in one boy swing the pendulum while
keeping the other boy rotation and
swinging back in
stuff one boy
swing a little bit
back in
if that's difficult you can
really just let one boy the complete
stop and get used to what it feels like
for this hand just not doing anything
spins Linda bringing back in in case you
try to be a pendulum it that your hands
like sort of freaked out go try to stay
but sometimes people will try to stop
the other hand
there we play with swinging in reversing
directions one point of time
so I'm alternating right hand and left
hand
so that was
actually
you can also
so forth all of those are really good
practices this isn't a particular
trigger remove all by itself it's a
concept that's something to take and
work on for months and months and months
in every possible decision that you can
find it because it's it's going to let
you really effortless way to
transition
between
opposite direction movement
arms crossed haha okay so you're still
listen we brought it all the way back to
basic spinning and
crossing as you review its extra
projector boy so we're spinning together
timing same directions and forward and
as the boy fall down from the ceiling
that's when it's safe to cross them all
what everybody not just poor bugger
bodybuilder
to cross them all the way over and then
you really just scooped up the upswing
here either side of me to get them to
stabilize so that it just
and of course you want to get
comfortable with this the right hand
crossing arm or the left hand crossing
over and you want to feel comfortable
crossing and stop anything keeping our
skrux controlling that crossing the
other one keeping that in control I
mentioned earlier perhaps what I'm going
to say here that in general would try to
control your planes you're getting to
some awkward cross position
on your back and your clean start
tipping on you
the upswing is what's important as the
point passes the ground is going to pass
that pull of gravity if they're really
scoop enough energy to the boy get all
the way back up into the top I think
like eighty ninety percent of people's
problems with playing control and
getting some auditing themselves is that
their paintings offer their just feeling
tentative and not quite getting enough
of
it over and so it sort of falls off of a
sign books are taking just remember that
if you're in an odd position in your
foyer like bending at you
scoop them up
bouncing a little bit and that will
really help control your planes
so from there we even played with just
further organs people something that a
lot of folks haven't actually tried
which is
basically a weaving on motion
so here's here's a three meeting we've
split time and together time
for
using the same honor motion but because
the koi have shifted their relationship
half a turn to get from split on the
same time I'm going to add a whole extra
be there for
the front and
a personal you at verse
all things
and that eventually nice too since we're
going to get hype is this true
but this sort of movement
eventually leads
we could are
[Music]
re hello